Hello Freak bitches.
I always think I'm almost through this,
so imagine we're the only civilization in the galaxy.
What a tremendous responsibility there is on us.
Imagine what that knowledge should do to our political processes,
the way that we think about ourselves,
the way that we get on together.
Imagine how ridiculous it is to divide our little world up into countries and
another little war every now and again,
important nuclear missiles at each other,
if in fact there's nowhere else in the Milky Way galaxy where anybody thinks
where anybody can look at the styles and think about and have these
conversations,
what a ridiculous way to behave.
So.
So I think the cosmology is gives a perspective which not doesn't necessarily
need to be humbling.
It is humbling and that's perhaps a good thing,
but it doesn't need.
You don't need to be depressed about it.
It could be quite elating.
You say,
well,
with what we are according to the evidence and the data at the moment is almost
indescribably special.
Our,
our tininess,
our potential uniqueness,
our insignificance in a cosmic scale actually makes us special because we're the
only place.
And so,
so these,
these ideas are worth pursuing,
I think because they,
they,
they make you think about these issues.
It doesn't.
It also point to our ego that we think that our biological processes any more
important than the exploding sons that are required to create carbon life in the
first place or,
or any of the processes of the universe.
The answer that I think is that you're right,
that in,
in a,
in a completely logical sense,
we're no more important or less important than the stars themselves.
You're right,
which is natural objects.
But I would counter by saying that people look for meaning in the universe.
People like to look for meaning.
It's this one thing that we've done since we began to look at the stars.
The universe means something to me.
It doesn't,
it,
it does.
Meaning exists because it means something to us.
So we know that it would be ridiculous to say the university is meaningless.
It means something in my relatives,
our families,
we have loved ones,
et cetera.
So the fact that that meaning might be emergent,
it might appear from the laws of nature.
And it is almost certainly transient,
unless we build these self replicating machines,
we will.
We're not going to last forever as a civilization probably so that to me,
that doesn't in any way water down the significance of it.
So I,
I think again,
cosmology can be,
can be a powerful aid to philosophical thoughts in this sense because we have to
accept that there's meaning in the universe because it means something to us.
I don't see why it has to be eternal.
I don't see why that meaning doesn't imply purpose.
I don't think there's any purpose to the universe,
brings any point to our existence,
but the fact that we exist at all is worth celebrating.
You don't need to add anything else.
In fact,
you almost did it to me.
You devalue it.
So why would you?
This is remarkable.
We emerged a single celled organisms before that will emerge in some chemical
reactions in,
in hydrothermal vents,
probably down in the deep primordial oceans of ancient earth.
And over three point 8 billion years,
we've come to the point where we can sit and think about the styles and have
conversations like this.
Is that not enough?
Can we just leave it there?
Why does it have to be a point?
There isn't a point.
I don't think it's appalling to that,
but it's worth celebrating because you don't think about it.
It's out of sight,
out of mind.
You don't have to look at it.
It's when you look at it and you know,
kind of like if you had to take a shit,
you know,
that's one thing you're like,
oh,
I can't wait to take a shit.
And he'd get on that toilet comes up.
But if you had a stuff that shit back in your asshole theater,
reach in there with rubber gloves on and just pack your own ass,
repack it.
That might be one of the worst things you could ever do.
Like taking a shit is amazing
when you hold it in for just a little bit,
not a long time.
He'll lecture extra 20 minutes and then you'd get on that toilet just,
ah,
you feel those logs just fucking barrel and down the river.
Boom,
boom,
boom.
I went to,
I had took a dump at the mall the other day.
I've been trying to eat healthier,
eating more Greens and stuff,
so it came out like very earthy.
Right.
It wasn't anything horrible.
It just smelled and I flushed and then the guy came in to clean the restroom and
started choking and I felt so good and he just hear him like trying to clean up
and then he just go at the end.
He just goes,
he was in there about two minutes.
He goes,
it smells like fucking shit.
Like oh yeah.
Like I said,
it was like a highlight of my life.
Yeah.
Like you scored on him.
He scored on them fucking shit in a bathroom.
That guy's got to go in there right after you.
And I had flushed.
So it wasn't like it was still sitting there stewing like it was post flush.
Well there's nothing worse than when you have to shit really bad.
And the only option is a Porta potty and you're at a concert and there's 20
people behind you and there's a long ass line and you go in there and you plop
down and you're shitting on other people's shit that is on top of other people's
Shit,
which is on other people's Shit,
which is all in smurf juice.
And you just drop dropping logs on top of preexisting logs and just gagging.
Meanwhile the band's playing your favorite song.
Freebird No.
Fuck
did you.
I saw this online.
They had a thing about the Porta potties,
like the whole point of him is you're supposed to close the lid and then that
will take the scent out up through this funnel,
like this tube and release sent up there.
But the reason Porta potty smells so bad is because everyone just leaves the lit
up.
No one wants to touch it.
Oh God.
Yeah.
Dylan bullshit.
It stinks.
It's a fucking confined space.
You're shitting in a phone booth.
It's not going.
That's smells everywhere.
Think as a society.
We could try it.
If it's still going to snake,
we can at least give it a shot.
You know?
I wish they movies.
Movies are like kids.
You don't.
People say,
do you have a favorite?
Fuck yeah,
but I'm not going to tell you.
You know,
like that's,
it's the same thing with kids.
It's like every parent,
I don't give a shit what they say.
I love them all equally.
No you don't because some kids are just assholes.
You can't possibly,
you know,
and,
and some of them are screw ups in life life children.
No,
I don't.
Yeah,
you can kind of love them all equally because I think when kids feel like
there's a part of it that's your fault,
that's the thing that people feel guilty.
You're saying guilt compensates for the lighter,
raises the love because you feel that they need more love because you screwed
them up.
You're responsible for there being a dog that killed one of my other dogs.
I love the dog that she killed,
but I loved her just as much and it was very sad.
I mean,
obviously I have loved the dog that got killed more because she wasn't a cunt,
she wasn't an asshole that was out there killing the other dogs,
but this dog was a sweetie and I picked her up at the pound and she lived at
the,
she was in one of those no kill shelters for like eight months.
And when I was young,
man I had a real problem in that.
It's hard to talk about I guess
where I felt like,
um,
I felt I had always had this,
uh,
this need to help strays and I think I had this need to help strays because I
felt like a stray and when I would see a,
a dog in a pound or a click,
I bought a cat from a fucking pet store because it hissed at me,
you know,
because I felt his poor fucking cat,
like scared of me.
I'm not scared of me.
I love you.
And I felt that way about this dog,
this poor dog.
I used to call her squeaky because when I picked her up she couldn't even talk.
She couldn't bark because she barked so much,
so often in this pound that her voice was gone.
So when she was barking in the pound,
she'd be like,
yeah,
it was like this squeak.
And I was like,
what the fuck is wrong with her voice?
And I realized,
Oh my God,
she's barking all day and she doesn't have a voice anymore.
And then when I took her home and took care of her,
she eventually got her voice back and she barked like a normal dog.
But that dog fucking loved people.
She loved people.
She was so happy to be out of that shit,
but she didn't like other dogs because the dogs came near her.
She felt like it was a competition for love.
Like if you came near another dog,
that other dog was going to get that love.
So she would get upset at that dog for stealing love from her and she would try
to attack it.
So I loved her too.
Equally,
even though she was an idiot,
you know,
she,
but it wasn't her fault that she was an idiot.
You know,
I would,
uh,
I realized from then on I will never get a dog that's not a puppy,
that you got to raise them from the time they're puppies because then you don't
have any,
they don't have any phobias or weirdness.
You get a chance to,
to raise them around people and raise them around other dogs and socialize them.
And it's an important aspect of humans just like it's an important aspect.
Any other animal that's in our culture.
So,
um,
you know,
I,
you can love your fucking shitty kids just as much as you love your good kids
because it's partly your fault that they're shitty.